asian games coming in 2016 in addition
to playing great games our fans are also
passionate about their entertainment a
year ago we gave you more choice by
bringing a new capability especially
meaningful to the fans here in Europe
free-to-air HD television on Xbox one
we've been listening to your feedback
and many of you have asked will they
ever be able to record live TV today I'm
pleased to announce the answer is yes
we're adding full-featured EBR
functionality to xbox one you can record
free-to-air TV schedule recordings and
take your shows on the go let me show
you how easy it is from the one guide I
can quickly select the show I want to
record and get back to watching TV or
playing one of my favorite games xbox
records my show in the background
without impacting my experience at all
with instant on enabled it will record
my shows even when I'm not at home
getting access to all of my recordings
is easy within the one guide I just go
to the DVR section and I can see all of
my shows dbr will be even better with
the Xbox app on Windows 10 all shows you
have recorded on Xbox one can also be
streamed to any Windows 10 device in
your home be it a tablet a laptop or a
phone even better you can also download
shows to your device so you can watch
them on an airplane on a bus really
anywhere even without an internet
connection because our DVR is powered by
xbox live you can also schedule
recordings even when you're on the go
and they'll show up back on your xbox
one best of all this is a subscription
free service and it's coming in 2016
we've also been hearing you ask for an
easier way to message with friends and
today I'm excited to announce the new
Xbox chatpad now you can quickly compose
messages inner codes and search for
games and apps you also get audio
controls at your fingertips and a stereo
jack Fred set the chatpad also comes
with two new programmable keys I'm
personally looking forward to taking
screenshots and recording game DVR clips
at the touch of a button the attach the
chatpad is compatible with all xbox one
controllers and works with both went
xbox one and Windows 10 it will be
available in November and you can
pre-order today at e3 we also announced
the ability to play xbox 360 games on
your xbox one since then we have been
humbled by the response in just over a
month the Xbox community has submitted
more than 3 million votes and preview
gamers have played over 83 years of xbox
360 games on their xbox one I'm happy to
announce that all future xbox 360 games
with gold titles will be backward
compatible at launch this means xbox one
and xbox live gold members get more free
to play each month at Xbox our first
party microsoft studios are committed to
backward compatibility allowing you to
play your top xbox 360 franchises like
halo Gears and fable on your xbox one
combined with support from leading
third-party publishers such as EA
Bethesda Ubisoft 2k and many more I'm
excited to announce backward
compatibility will be available for
everyone for free this November with
over 100 games 100 more to come
in addition to backward compatibility in
November we're updating Xbox one with
Windows 10 and releasing a completely
redesigned experience that will be
faster and easier than ever before
November is going to be a great time for
Xbox fans thank you and have a great
week here at Gamescom